I want us to do something that will be
tiny bit more general speak about some
openings ideas I would like to make
effort to review pretty much all the
openings even if it will be one or two
minutes per opening go some ideas and
mentioned players that play them in
reading just get so you know get to know
some names that maybe some of you never
heard of for example the French opening
what is the French opening can someone
tell me which moves white need to play
white and black to get to the French
opening right yeah you know want to tell
me no okay so we will start reviewing
open before we even play move we can say
that in general openings in chess can be
divided into two main categories - huge
different world yes Adi right King pawn
which is evil pretty much was the only
way to play chess up until I would maybe
hundred years ago something like that oh
definitely hundred fifty years ago
everyone played like this and not only
that was like everyone was playing this
way by Kings gambit everyone was playing
it but because at that time the way to
win a chess game was really by checkmate
but right now we know that chess is not
about checkmate right chess is about
winning material getting more space it's
a much more strategical game then well
just checkmate so we see many more
openings that are much more positional
and the game is much much slower now
efore is one the other side of openings
that are dimensioned correctly there are
Queen side openings or maybe tiny flank
openings openings on the side will be
default which is may move Queen pawn and
then Knight f3 which is basically like
before it's basically like this move why
because deny controls the same square
that the D pawn control so basically
they are both controlling the same
square so this point Knight f3 are
pretty much the same though small
differences yes right but he's
controlling that square right meaning if
you step into a five you're under its
territory and the other last one which
is pretty much the same family is to
play c4 because many of the openings
with c4 being followed by default Queen
side openings so we have e fo okay what
would be logical moves here for black to
play yes most logical move would be e
five why do you want to play five
excellent reason and perfectly correct
the center is most important right these
even Bend can testify we have mentioned
repeatedly repeatedly okay that's it
my conscience is clear so we care about
the center right because the center
gives us possibilities to go to many
different sides of the board right just
much easier to be in the center and
thing I want to take here I want to go
here rather than being on the side and
you have less mobility right so II five
immediately fighting for the crucial
second important square in the center
the d4 square right I'm going to
repeatedly say the name of the square
not saying like well it's fighting for
our death square next to the pawn no
this disk one has a name right D always
the letter four that's how we speak
right
so we are fighting for the default
square all right
'if I've agree what's the name of a five
in general what would be the name of
that opening to be Spanish opening I
mean then we will go in there are many
more small lines in it but in general it
will be the Spanish opening the main
line yes when Lopez is what is the main
line there but not when I was just going
there the way Lopez is Knight f3
attacking the central pawn now blacks
main move is night develop night see
sticks and defend upon alternatively
this is another very major move it's
called the Russian defense or patch of
attacking white central pawn but most
kids in tournaments here will play one
move pretty automatically which move
would you play yes why to play bishops
if there was you all going to say
Charlie ah Bishop c4 that's pretty much
what everyone's playing white rubbish
Bishop c4 is their Italian opening right
so we have a big line like the Spanish
and this is a sideline over line within
a big opening and you will you will keep
hearing that most of the openings are
names of either but whichever location
like a city a country sometimes well
areas but mostly mostly countries all
named after notable chess players either
it's a world champion or a very known
grandmaster or anything like that all
right
yes
yes that's two so we have Bishop which
of c4 and Bishop b5 which is the Ray
Lopez basically King Lopez right Spanish
opening now we have for example d4 which
actually was played 101 more than
hundred years ago and then became like
nobody played it until a player under
the name of Gary Kasparov we heard about
this player not a really bad chess
player right until a player under the
name of Gary Kasparov brought it back to
life in his match in 1990 against
Anatoly Karpov towards the world
championship match couple was world
champion from 75 till 85 in Kasparov in
karpova's F played several big fellow of
the big matches in chess history between
84 1984 to 1990 like they played one two
three four five matches in like 130 2030
games like so in one of the actually
more play almost hundred fifty forty
fifty so in one of those matches in 1990
Kasparov played the Scotch opening
that's the name of it
scotch another not named after the drink
maybe more after Scotland alright and
there you know for example there is this
93 Knight f6 which has the very very
creative name of yes the four Knights
right I mean we have we have you know
Italian opening when you pass scotch
then we're for night you know okay I can
see that there are four Knights
developed but that's the name they give
it okay I'm I'm not in the name
Department anyway so those are really
the main openings that are coming from
efore f5 and like what said so correctly
before black main reason is just to
to all the default group immediately all
right
another major opening for black after
'if oh yes
ethics okay if six is exam so if he
thinks is different defense why almost
ten minutes ago when I was asking hey
French defense who can tell me how we
get to the French defense yes he alright
ah no is it okay
Batista's is different very very correct
now but we throw the French defense I
want something before that yes of course
we find it has to be c5 and the name is
Sicilian yes next to Italy home base of
some very big serious mobsters right and
not bad pizza so that's true so c5 is
actually by far the most played opening
in in the world by far here by far
because it has endless amount of
possibilities it's controlling the same
square as default as if I saw the same
square that if I've controls but it's
just doing it in not a symmetrical way
so the games get to be much more dynamic
I mean it doesn't mean well black is
better it doesn't mean it's a better
move the knee 5 just mean that it's a
much more dynamic opening than if I were
at least considered that way and many
great players have played it including
Kasparov and Fischer in the NAND and
many of the greatest players in history
have played Sicilian yes
on the first move so you can chat to
your bishop by putting the bishop on
this square
it's called fianchetto your bishop no
idea why that's how they call it yeah
that don't that would be under the type
of flank opening because you are playing
in the side of the board not directly in
the center they are played and played by
many strong players but for example
magnus carlsen play them a bit even in
the match against Anand in view of the
beginning games but actually he didn't
get really too much with them they are
though as any other openings main ones
but consider tiny bit less principle
because you are not immediately fighting
for the center really right of course
but but but for example one disadvantage
can be if black plays this which is one
of the main systems to play so AHA so
you're going to have this wall against
your bishop right there are two players
this play right and your opponent it's
not your friend right well preferably
not but sometimes it happens nothing to
do right so you need to practice harder
when that happened but I mean let's put
it this way there is no opening that is
better than other clearly better in main
openings it just doesn't doesn't go this
way because then everyone will play that
if someone comes and tells you hey this
opening is just bad well yeah if someone
plays rubbish right if someone plays
this but that's not a real opening but
to say to someone hey you know the
Sicilian is much better than the French
kind of wrong it's actually very very
wrong because each opening has these
advantages and disadvantage what we are
seeing right now
for example c5 is opposed to e5 fighting
for the same key squares only that it
does it in not a symmetrical way so the
game will be more dynamic and both of
those move are doing exactly the same
now a question ethics the French defense
what is the most logical move for white
to play here yes raising your hand so
quickly I will have to answer you even
faster yes d4 this one of course if we
can get something in the center why
shouldn't we right I mean we know our
principles right get pawns in the center
develop the pieces castle get the roots
in the game kind of very very in one
breath we should say the d4
what should black play yes d5 and here
white has several possibilities yes if I
which is called very surprisingly
they're the advanced variation because
you move your pawn forward advanced
advanced variation and there are several
other major continuations Knight c3
defending the pawn Knight d2 another way
to defend the pawn bless you and the
exchange variation so we have different
different lines now question does white
have more space than black here
equal amount of space okay you know I
was never I never liked really geometry
but let's see my skill so this is the
boat this is half of the board this is
the pawn on d4 and this is the pawn on
d5 right isn't white pawn like China
more advanced than black so that means
white controls more space right alright
so white is more space right now we know
that space is important right so then
there someone should ask me a question
right space space is good but black
strategy here is saying oh you advance
too much which is a big strategy in war
okay you are leaving witnesses behind I
will attack you exactly such as playing
c5 and then if the pawn will move this
pawn is left really really weak so C 3
can be played and this is an opening
play by many of the world best player
for example they will Cohen 12 champion
Magnus Carlsen play the French previous
world champion just up until November
2013
Anand used to play the French in his
early career world champion petrosyan
play the French regularly three times
vice world champion Viktor Korchnoi play
the French it's an opening of highest
level yet it gives white in some in some
line more space but also well it gives
black counter play against this space
this is a very important thing to
remember there are no really major bad
openings each one has exactly exactly so
if your opponent like was said so
correctly get a lot of space well it
should be clear that you can manage that
excellent now an opening let's look at
this structure an opening that is very
similar to that structure but not
exactly is we said e 5 Spanish
see five Sicilian fighting for the d4
square e six is the French and black
wanna play d5 the fourth super major
opening is c6 name what's the name very
good very good
named after two people choose the two
name name of two separate people travel
and come right in after what is most
logical move for white here yes right
it's the main move there are other lines
such as 93 for example which is
surprisingly the two knights and other
but of course d4 is most principal
gating and black is most logical move is
going to be d5 and pretty much almost
identical as in the French white can
play e5 that gets the beautiful name of
their advance variation 93 and 92 I
think I'll call the classical one and
capture for example Bobby Bobby Fischer
played this now there are two major
lines that's the exchange variation if
you go Bishop d3 go if you shall be
Petrosian in a very very known game all
c4 which is a line named panel Botvinnik
after well panel was a great planner but
Winnick one of the greatest world
champions most names as we said named
after player names of players or
locations and if if five what is the big
idea of black playing the car walk on as
opposed to the fridge someone wakes you
at 2:00 in the morning tells you hey I
couldn't go to sleep I have to know what
is the difference between the French and
the kavik on what is the most basic
difference what is it you know if you
don't know I'll have to wake you three
Wow
I didn't know that now tell me what
what's the real difference don't tell me
what's on the board we have left late c6
and no t6 but what's the difference from
that black black and do what you can but
you will be one move down a Tempe down I
mean black and play e6 and then c5 but
then what is the genius part of playing
c6 and n35
not understanding but you are right that
it's c6 and not e6 but what's the real
reason
what should let play here yes but then
you will get like the previous position
it would be like the previous position
only that you are when you will play c5
you just wasted a move because you
played c6 and then c5 yes f6 tiny bit to
weakening for this king you know no no
this this pawn let it be though I mean I
know you want to challenge the center
it's not actually the idea itself at
some point f6 will be played but not
right now
I have a question what about this Bishop
is it blocked right now that's the big
difference so black will play most
likely Bishop f5 get the bishop out and
then play sticks so the main difference
between the French to the Kulkarni's
well the bishop can go out on the other
hand what is the cost for black in many
lines extra move if he wants to play c5
it's playing 365 that's everything in
chess right nothing for free but the
crowd is a matter of taste where you can
get your Bishop out but then you will
play c5 in two moves and not in one is
the French the French you can play it in
one move but then the bishop gets locked
everything like that okay so those are
the four major openings against t4
Spanish Sicilian French Calcutta
then we have some some let's plate
openings but by no means bad ones but
there are some what giving white maybe
tiny bit too much of the center somehow
one opening is the pits
named after a player form X
Czechoslovakia peers or modern defense
and white will play d4 okay this is
aligned it is being played by enough
grandmasters Bobby Fischer played I
think one did you play one game in no he
actually dream playing the world champ
maybe it did I member us to say don't
even remember in the World Championship
against Spassky he played the other kind
I don't think he played any peers but it
was played in several world championship
games it's not considered many
Grandmaster played but in World
Championships matches for example very
rarely we are going to see this line ok
but it's extremely reasonable why it
gets tiny bit more space and it's not
immediately under attack blacks idea is
to build a counter-attack against whites
enter d5 the name of it is Scandinavian
Oh counter Center well very logically
black is immediately challenging white
in the center what's the disadvantage
here should be happy you took white
central pawn away but white can play now
93 yeah but so why to play 93 the Queen
moves
I mean Queen d6 is possible so this is
tiny against the logic of one
don't move one piece too many times in
the opening and to definitely not your
queen as one of those pieces right but
on the other hand white lost is pawn
advantage in the center
it's another opening that's being
reasonable and played for example Anand
we mentioned him he played this in the
game against Kasparov in the World
Championship match in actually New York
1995 in New York there was one game with
this opening but it's a very rare very
rarely we see those at World
Championship matches actually I think
it's the only one that we've seen in a
such level but still many grandmasters
play this black-white get extra move at
MP right Knight c3 attacking the Queen
the Queen moves twice on the other side
why doesn't heavy center and the left
opening for example data dimension
Fischer played against Spassky is Alec
I'm named after yes what was this dude
nobody now
should give you going with ten hours of
chess history each it was the fourth
world champion it was the fourth world
champion the first world champion was
Stein its last kal Capablanca and then
alaka'i and actually he was the only
world champion that actually died while
being world champion so after after he
died they couldn't make a match to
determine who will be the next world
champion so they had a tournament with
the best player in the world and the
winner of the tournament was Botvinnik
in 1948 and he became the world champion
by winning a tournament so 96 what is
the disadvantage of this what should
white play here d4 is not going to work
you right
no no d4 here we want to put our pawns
if preferably two maybe sometimes even
three more than that is already on the
verge of you know maybe it's too much in
the center because what the pawns are
really doing the pawns are really
marking the territory at the beginning
of the game where is white territory
where is black and what is the big
battle that follow after it well each
side is trying to break through the
opponent territory you so you put your
pawns then you develop the pieces tiny
bit behind them to support those squares
and then everyone's battle around it so
the faster you can get the space the
better now if one player is developing
these pieces and not having pawns around
it they can be pushed away that's that's
a very important idea to understand the
pawns of the one that's saying you
cannot cross this territorial you should
not cross so in this position d3 is okay
move but principally it's wrong because
what is preventing why to play e5 and
make this Knight move again
thing so that's why it's the right move
and then we develop for example this is
one line okay this is one major line
okay so what is supposed to be tiny
better here because only has two central
pawns for free tiny better no not no
nothing you know
but what suppose a cliff theoretically
supposed to be better here I mean this
is also possible might okay those are
different line but the logic is the D
point of the one guitar marking the
territory at the beginning of our game
so those are seven major openings
against a foe I know that we did it
quite quickly but do you think that is
there anyone to think you cannot mention
all of them if you will mention them I
will play them on the board you think so
alright come on shoot Spanish alright
efore e5 controlling the d4 square yes
French in four is six the idea is to
play tiny bit form the back but making
effort to especially attack white d4
pawn in many situation alrighty
Sicilian basically we want to control
this square and get when y to play d4 we
will exchange the sepal for the day and
get dynamic and symmetrical position
okay caro-kann very similar to which
opening and in a last attempt to prevent
getting awake at 3:00 in the morning
what's the difference major difference
between them
so the bishop can be developed right
very good okay I want to see if we can
get all of them
primo Alec I'm right 96 and white major
move will be e 5 because well you can
gain tiny bit more space and black make
black piece move again right
named after default world champion - mo
d 6 do you remember the one with the six
yes very good
named after a platform past existing
Czechoslovakia I think I think it was a
Czech actually not from Slovak
right and this is this is the main the
major line tiny space for white black
will play slowly and make effort to
challenge the center so that was the
that is the pure defence of perk and
last one is yes
so for Knight is a side line within
their Spanish yes
Scandinavian d5 the advantage taking
away White's pawn disadvantage
right I'm being posed to move the Queen
that's what you're gonna say perfect
okay so that's quite quite enough about
efore now we have d for openings while
which moves will be major moves for
black after D for major move right
exactly the same logic as before right
basically what are the other key squares
in the center right okay black will make
effort immediately to control them which
other move is key move here yes
Knight to f6 is the second major move
exactly exactly
mmm so somewhat on the first move black
has a bit less replies than on e4 but
after they will get many more lines
what's the idea of 96 exactly the same
as d5 controlling their ethos Square and
especially this one now white can play
c4 and then we are getting into Queen
side opening ethics will be will lead to
many lines g6 will lead to King's Indian
of goons field this will be named during
many many different lines I want to
touch just one point regarding d4 d5
main move for white is c4 now if we can
say something in just half a minute
the main common wisdom let's put it this
way common wisdom is saying that ego is
more aggressive because you're in many
lines going more to attack the King and
all those lines like in the Spanish of
Sicilian and that d4 is more positional
play you play more for space controlling
territory it's much more strategical
positional as opposed to e4 which is
more tactical well in some way it's true
but of course you know young players
play really only e fo when you go up I
think II for Wendy for being split kinda
evenly with world champion grandmasters
and so on you're going to see as
something are delicious too did you have
a question no howdy
but it's not gonna lose material which
moves our logical hero4 black after c4
yeah ii six you know the name but if the
Queen's Gambit and ethics is Queen's
Gambit no no yes I D decline because
black also can capture the pawn right
which would be accepted even I know that
the opposite of decline is accept right
so and and it's not really a gambit what
what if I do a definition of gambit or
kinda definition of gambit yes
right basically it's sacrificing a pawn
sometimes too but usually one for
advantage in development in space that's
pretty much would be our definition or
something like that exactly but this is
not really a sacrifice because white can
get the pawn pretty black is not
defending the pawn it's not correct for
black to defend apart so we have in this
position Queens gambit declined which is
the most classical reply against d4 d5
was pretty much played in every World
Championship match all most of them like
kappa blanka really are in pretty much
every game no that's insane
pretty much every game it's in this
opening or pretty much every game
because power of Karpov in a long series
of games in this pretty much every World
Championship had seen this opening yes a
six Queens gambit declined take Queens
gambit accepted and c6 is there slab
defense get the name now I've seen
endless amount of kids such as the one
here they play Knight f6 and this is a
wrong move but so many played this you
know I just want to touch this topic and
then Ben is going to take it not this
one the other one I'm going to take it
next week and then you will get you sir
so after Knight f6 what should white
play here yes that's the wall
I'm usually I speak to the wall but now
I speak to you yes
Knight c3 black will play ecigs guess
what we transposed into Queens gambit
declined it's like in this position play
here here here can we transpose into a
major line I'm saying that 96 is kind of
wrong because white is something better
than transposed to a major one yes he
takes d5 that's the difference now what
is black is going to take with the Queen
white is going to play 93 it's some sort
of like the Scandinavian but even a
better version because White's going to
get another pawn in the center so that's
not OK for black and if Knight takes d5
white is going to play
I'm also saying if oh and how do you say
if also so I'd get the center for free
and kickin black again so you see that's
illogical that's wrong for black like
should not allow Y to get to play this
and so many so many beginners they
naturally play all night f6 that's
already wrong because what are the pawns
doing remember the pawns are the one
tech mark the territory say okay you
know this is my IDC zeros and then we
fight all over it so for example in this
position okay white is tiny space
advantage tiny big putty is white black
is controlling those squares white is
controlling those white is putting tiny
pressure on d5 but that is a normal game
of chess if one player gets easily two
pawns in the center and the opponent
doesn't even f1 its many times tiny bit
better those were you know just a tiny
door to our openings and there are some
great books including one book that is
written by us so that's going to come
here which is yes winning chess openings
and several other decent books that will
give you may be tiny larger introduction
to the base of the game